bonsoir monsieur je consomme ses clients
pire semaine en deux ans sur les marchés
pourquoi une réaction selon vous aussi
négative sur les marchés face à la
hausse des taux avec les risques de
récession pourquoi la réaction était
aussi négative
j'ai envie de l'x et la fin des
illusions il vous et moi nous savons
pour les conversations nous avons vu
précédemment que nous nous trouvons
vraiment dans une situation que le
marché a profondément sous-estimé qui
était une situation dans laquelle la
combinaison des problèmes qui se posent
à nous et particulièrement la politique
contestée par les banques centrales a
effectivement créé un déséquilibre qui
devait retomber je vous avoue très
sincèrement que de mon point de vue à
moi ce n'est pas ce que j'appellerais
une réaction violente pour le moment
j'ai encore l'impression que la baisse
des cours qui va continuer est une plus
ou moins sous contrôle dans le central
le problème c'est que les banques
centrales ont contrôle d'une partie de
l'inflation est pas de la totalité est
ce que donc ce bear market ce marché
baissier dans lequel est engagé
maintenant le marché new yorkais selon
vous et je crois le comprendre là va se
poursuivre longtemps va s'accélérer
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
écoutez pour le moment on ne voit
absolument pas d'où pourrait revenir une
réaction positive
je ne pense pas que la hausse des taux
de la federal reserve soit terminé ceci
dit j'ai l'impression qu'il va y avoir
une certaine stabilité et c'est de ce
côté là que je suis d'accord avec
l'attitude de la federal reserve on peut
dire ils ont fait beaucoup oui mais d'un
autre côté ils ont créé un climat dans
lequel ils ne vont pas devoir tout le
temps se poser la question de 25 ans une
page de plus 25 points de base depuis
sedan venez on va entrer dans une
situation où les taux d'intérêt longs se
remettre
l'inflation elle n'est pas sous contrôle
et comme jeudi la banque centrale fait
ce qu'elle peut et si vous voulez on a
connu une récession pire que celle ci
sous paul volcker et le bord de la
federal reserve est en train de suivre
ce que voeckler le fait donc on remonte
au début des années 80
absolument et n'a connu à l'oublier des
taux d'intérêt
à double chiffre et de l'inflation à
double chiffre
ouais est ce que quand on entend plus de
65 je sais plus que ça même on est
pratiquement à 80% des hauts dirigeants
qui prévoit une récession dans les 12 à
18 mois aux etats-unis est-ce que vous
êtes de cet avis également
alors je suis dans la minorité de ceux
qui croient qu on y est déjà
donc je sens maintenant toute une série
d'éléments dans l'économie de frein mais
je voudrais aussi que les
téléspectateurs ne considère pas que la
récession est un épouvantail à moineaux
où tout le monde s'enfuit
l'économie américaine a baissé de 1,4
pour cent au premier trimestre elle
était déjà en récession alors hier les
définitions techniques qui disent il
faut 3 me au trimestre d'affilée la
réalité s'est cognée et donc je crois
qu'à la fois on est en tout cas
stagflation parce que nous ne rendrons
compte cartonné sur l'économie et que
les prix augmentent combien de temps
pourrait durer
cette récession cette forme de marasme
économique
sur base de l'expérience américaine
j'aurais tendance à dire que c'est le
genre d'opération qui va se situer au
maximum sur une période de trois ans
mais ça ne sont pas être une période de
baisse pendant trois ans il va y avoir
de la baisse et de la remontée je pense
que nous avons devant nous trois ans
difficile ce sera beaucoup plus
difficile pour le japon où pour l'europe
mais pas trois ans de récession
non on va avoir une récession on va
devoir prendre des mesures pour gérer la
réception et progressivement on va
récupérer les moyens d'action et donc on
va retrouver j'allais dire le niveau de
2022 beaucoup de gens s'entendent pour
dire que les banques centrales ont agi
avec beaucoup trop de retard ont eu des
problèmes d'évaluation de l'inflation
l'année passée même chez nous la banque
du canada reconnaît d'ailleurs des
erreurs à ce niveau là est-ce qu'on
augmente à l'est le taux directeur comme
et comme la banque le fait la banque
centrale aux états unis de 75 points de
base est ce que vous diriez que la fed
fait ce qu'il faut ou agit peut-être
finalement trop vigoureusement
selon vous
non je trouve que le ce qu'a fait le
président escalettes sera bon pour la
raison que je vous expliquais étant
donné qu'il a fait 75 points de base
ouais on zappe avec l'épée de damoclès
dans les prochains mois première chose
d'autre part pour leur parti qui
concerne les banques centrales
n'oublions pas que le pompier a été le
pyromane et donc il sait mieux que
quiconque ce qu'il faut faire pour
essayer d'éteindre le feu la russie
ferme progressivement le robinet gazier
en ce moment et en même temps le prix du
pétrole chutent en raison de quoi en
raison du fait qu'on est en récession ou
qu'on prévoit vraiment une récession
je ne crois pas que c'est une question
de demande
s'il y avait une récession ça vous a dit
qu'on a besoin de moins de produits je
crois qu'il y à une diminution de
l'offre mais qu' il y a eu en abandonner
la crainte de voir que tous les robinets
allait se fermer et on se rend compte
maintenant qu'on va pas voir me pouvoir
vivre et que notamment pour cet été il
n'y a pas de problème de gaz mais le
problème de pétrole et donc ça c'est un
tout petit peu stabilisé mauvais quand
même encore succès
au dessus d'eux au dessus des 100
dollars effectivement le baril tout à
fait bien on s'arrête là-dessus georges
du jeu merci d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir
comme toujours réfléchir chiant pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]